today I want to show you a very unique
way to get rid of that really stubborn
belly fat if you're female or male we're
going to talk about the differences I'm
going to talk about if it's better to
use exercise or diet or other techniques
but for most of you watching this is
probably new information that you've
never heard before so definitely take
notes one of the things that I think is
very important before you jump into
solving any problem is to really
understand the problem a little bit more
so when we're dealing with belly fat
we're dealing with
you know there's different names for IT
central obesity visceral fat abdominal
obesity there's a lot of different names
for this belly fat and so this type of
fat is very different than your
superficial fat it's called subcutaneous
that's just underneath the skin belly
fat or visceral fat is fat that is
ectopic which means it's outside the fat
cell the fat is in the organs and it's
especially in your liver so in other
words if you have belly fat you have
liver fat and it is essential to get rid
of the fat off the liver uh to get rid
of this midsection weight now there's
quite a few mistakes people make when
they're trying to deal with this they're
they're at the gym trying to do spot
exercises where they're doing sit-ups
and crunches for weeks months and
they're not seeing any change they go on
a diet and many times that won't work
either unless it targets the liver so
I'll just give you a little picture of
what's Happening Here so we have liver
that is filling up with fat it's
spilling off into the midsection around
the organs in your visceral that's the
all the organs in the mid part of your
belly and this is called ectopic fat and
what's really going on behind the scenes
is there's this hormone called insulin
and insulin is is a fat storing hormone
it also prevents you from losing uh your
fat so there's a lot of insulin being
pumped out by the pancreas and then
that's turning into insulin resistance
which makes it really hard to lose
weight because the body is pumping out
so much insulin and that insulin
communication is store fat store fat
store fat and then this ectopic fat
basically creates insulin resistance so
it's a NeverEnding cycle and of course
you may already know that carbohydrates
and sugars and things like that increase
insulin but also there's something
called gluconeogenic genis that's where
your liver is making new sugar and if
you have insulin resistance your liver
will make sugar not even from the sugar
that you eat in the diet it can actually
be converting other things to sugar and
it's kind of a double-edged sword
because you have your own liver making
sugar which is then converting into more
fat and making more fat so I I need to
kind of explain how to correct this
there are six things we're going to talk
about and one of the solutions is not to
detoxify the liver that is not going to
going to work and yes exercise can help
but not as a direct way to burn off the
fat it's more to use up the energy also
to help your stress and also to help you
sleep better because not only is it the
carbs that raise insulin but also the
stress activates a hormone called
cortisol and cortisol is a sugar hormone
and it will release sugar in fact it's
called
glucocorticoid if you take a look at
some of the synthetic versions of Cor
that they use as medications like
prazone for all sorts of inflammatory
conditions if you look at the side
effect it's major weight gain especially
in your midsection if you look up
excessive production of cortisol you
will see a picture of someone's belly
why because cortisol mobilizes different
tissues and turns your muscles into fat
so let me just talk about this right now
reducing
stress
but with with more sleep through the
type of exercise that I've did a whole
video on this aerobic
exercise if you can see that no you
can't see that so I'm gonna write down
right here
arobic what is this that's walks long
walks best way to reduce stress or
physical work around the house very very
important for reducing stress CU it
takes the mind off things but you want
low intensity long duration walks it's
going to help not necessarily burn off
the fat but it's going to help burn off
the adrenaline and the cortisol that's
flowing through the body from the stress
reduces stress it's going to help you
sleep and it will burn off some calories
as well but let me just kind of talk
about burning calories off and what do I
mean by that well the energy Factory of
the body is called the mitochondria
right here okay and um the purpose of
the mitochondria is to take your
calories and then turn it into chemical
fuel called ATP ATP is like the battery
of the body and so the mitochondria is
the battery maker okay and what it's
doing it's it's extracting energy from
food and it's turning it into this right
here so then it can be used what's
interesting about this ATP is that not
stored okay so you don't really have a
lot of stored ATP at any one time very
small amount so here's the thing you
need to know what can we do to increase
more ATP production and burning that's
the question well that relates to
exercise so exercise does have an
important factor um especially if you
understand that when you compare someone
at rest versus when they're exercising
you can increase the production of ATP
by a thousand times by intense
exercise so I do recommend doing uh
periodic uh intense exercise it's called
high-intensity interal training with The
Walking for various reasons one is to
start using up some of this energy right
here we want to use up the fat right
here right and we want to add the right
type of exercise and we want to do
high-intensity full body type exercise
you can do sprinting up a hill you can
do uh spin bike you can do weights any
type of exercise that will increase a
great amount of demand for energy and
then that's going to tap into your
reserve which is the midsection fat over
here a couple things you need to know
about exercise um you want to make sure
you don't overtrain because if you
overtrain it's going to increase stress
so it's very very important exercise U
like high intensity maybe three times a
week maybe two times a week recently I
am running up hills for exercise like
really major intense Hill running I
think I'll end up doing it maybe twice a
week not three times a week because my
body doesn't recover and I do have a a
machine or a test to determine that
that's going to be another video but the
point is that it's very easy to
overtrain I will get much better results
if I uh let my body rest in between this
high-intensity exercise and plus the
high-intensity exercise will stimulate
growth hormone which is the main fat
burning hormone but only if you are
sleeping okay so I should put down right
here right you can't see that
sleep okay sleep to get more well you
can't even see that right let's put it
right
here okay sleep so that's really
important to help with the stress dress
and sleep are in the same category it's
gon it's going to really help you
because it's kind of like a foundational
thing if you're not sleeping because
you're stressed
out good luck with losing weight why
because the cortisol prevents you from
uh tapping into this fat and especially
if you're trying to get rid of the
midsection very important and this is
why I'm spending a bit more time on it
all right number two what's happening in
your liver is the liver is fatty and so
it's spilling off so we must use up
the fat on your liver okay now there's
two uh things that you can do to get
yourself into what's called ketosis
which is um a type of fat burning right
because when your body burns fat or when
you eat fat that's mobilize into a more
easily packaged type of energy called
ketones that's why your body makes
ketones it can also run on fat fuel as
well but ketones are like a better
packaged fat fuel so there's two sources
of ketones one is your own fat and
number two is the dietary fat and here's
the thing to be able to tap into either
one of these fats you must reduce your
carbs right so the reduction of carbs is
important and you probably already know
that we must reduce the carbs but
reducing the carbs will force your body
to either burn fat from the calories
that you eat or your own fat
now let's talk about do we want to burn
calories from the fat that you eat or do
we want to burn your own stored fat well
that's a easy question we want to burn
our own stored fat so yes it is true
that the amount of calories of fat on
the ketogenic diet are much higher than
other diets but if you are trying to
lose weight in your midsection adding a
lot more dietary fat is not going to
help you so I'm going to recommend
especially for this situation is not to
start adding additional fat don't go
lowfat but don't add a lot of fat don't
add the MCT oil don't add the keto bombs
and desserts just don't do that because
your body is going to tap into that as
fuel and not your own fat now I do
recommend for some people to eat more
fat to help them be more satisfied so
they can actually go longer within a
minute fasting in the beginning of a
program but if we're trying to quickly
and rapidly get rid of this midsection
fat um you don't want to add a lot of
fat to your diet unless you want to
maintain your weight so we want to right
here reduce dietary fat okay but not to
the point of going low fat so don't go
below like 75 grams of fat per day
I would just consume your fat from the
normal proteins in nature that just come
with the fat whether it's meat eggs and
things like that don't go low fat don't
eat the egg whites alone but what we're
trying to do is we're trying to force
your body to tap into mainly your own
fat okay so that's number three number
four the real problem that you have is
in the liver okay because the liver is
the organ that is overfilled with fat
and it's spilling off into the abdominal
area so in other words you're going to
have to do things to get this fat off
the liver and heal it and make it really
healthy if it was healthy chances are it
can deal with all this extra fat and not
have so much insulin resistance okay
because insulin resistance is a
condition that it's like a pre-diabetic
condition metabolic syndrome you have a
lot of issues with that and you're
definitely going to have a lot more
insulin and a lot more fat in the
midsection so anything we can do for the
liver is going to be very very important
so what can we do for the
liver well we already lower the carbs
and some people can actually lose 50% of
their fat off their liver within two
weeks getting on the low carb diet but
there are three important
things that you can take to supplement
and help heal the liver the one is apple
cider vinegar
that greatly improves insulin it greatly
helps a fatty liver it greatly makes
insulin more sensitive to allow the
insulin to work better in the body so
what you do is you take a tablespoon of
Aleta vinegar put it in 12 ounces of
water I like to put lemon in there too
and maybe some electrolytes and I'll
drink that once twice or even three
times a day very significant changes can
occur if you do that the type of apple
Ceta vinegar I use is from from
fairchilds not brags because they don't
dilute it it's nice and strong and it's
a really good company the second very
important supplement is called milk
thistle milk thistle is amazing it's
that
pricky plant that has those purple
flowers that then turn into these white
little things at the end of a seed that
look like parachutes and so the wind
blows you can see them all around um in
the fields where I live anyway and
they're all over the place milk thistle
is a very unique plant and you can get
milk thisle seeds in tablet form what's
so unique about it it has super high-end
liver protecting
properties that basically it's like the
antidote to a snake poisoning or a
mushroom poison the most deadly mushroom
is called the death capat mushroom I
mean the antidote is milk thistle I mean
it's quite amazing amazing Tylenol
poisoning people that drink alcohol this
can help protect the liver but it's also
really important for a fatty liver in
correcting a fatty liver as well as
reducing
inflammation on a liver and also
protecting the liver from getting
therosis and helping with this
gluconeogenesis issue where your your
liver is producing a lot more sugar
because it has insulin resistance so it
helps with a lot of different aspects of
that liver as well was helping with
midsection weight and I put some
research down below you can check it out
okay so milk thistle is a given the
third thing is berberine and there's
several studies that show combining
berberine with milk thistle is a good
idea berberine is kind of I look at it
like a natural metformin without the
side effects but of course I'm not
making that claim and also I don't want
to make any claims in milk thisle Okay
so all I can say is you can read the
research and it's pretty amazing um with
the research that's done on mice so you
know you can apply it to humans if you
want but the point is that if it works
on mice maybe it can work on you but
berberine is a really good one uh with
the milk thistle H it's good for
diabetics and pre-diabetics and it helps
the liver with this extra glucon
neogenesis one thing I want to mention
about people trying to lose weight you
know I watch people through the year go
through this cycle and it's like this
pattern uh they just go crazy between
Thanksgiving and Christmas and New Years
and then they start all over again and
they go through this New Year's
resolution I think um emotions and
intelligence are
inverted people get wrapped up in
emotions at social activities birthday
parties events holidays going out to
dinner with friends and I watch this and
the intelligence or the IQ with Foods
goes out the window people don't really
learn from their mistakes you know like
they keep going in these same patterns
over and over and over again because
they're they're eating things that they
know are bad for the liver and they're
drinking alcohol that they know is bad
for the liver but they still do it
because they're wrapped up in the
emotions so I'm going to recommend that
you step back for a second and really
re-evaluate um your environment and the
people around you and uh just don't get
in those situations you know change the
habits in a person with uh belly fat you
have to realize that's not just a minor
thing it's pathological it's disease
creating it's creating inflammation it's
creating problems in your liver you
might not see it inside but it's not a
healthy State and so usually a person
with belly fat doesn't have the luxury
of continuing these bad habits over
again because they're just doing the
wrong things they must Focus focus on
changing their habits that's the most
important thing they need to focus on
because they're in this habit and
they're going through the cycle but the
point is for me I had to hit bottom
before I made changes I was the worst I
ate the worst food all the way up until
my late 20s I mean I just wouldn't eat a
little junk food I would eat a
tremendous amount of junk food pots of
coffee pots of chocolate I would never
eat anything like vegetables or celery
any of that stuff I only ate pure junk
food for so many years I had to hit
bottom and even when I hit bottom it
took me many years to feel terrible
before I said you know it's not worth it
anymore so uh now my liver is like a
barometer if I go off the program like
my body does not react well if I were to
drink alcohol I just would want to go to
sleep I think that's a good thing
because I never in a million years would
have gotten into health if I didn't have
these health problems so I have a lot of
personal experience doing this and I do
know I used to get wrapped up in the
emotion of it and I've corrected that
okay but for some people it takes them a
bit longer before they learn from their
mistakes and then number five is um
omed one meal a day in a minute fasting
if this doesn't happen right here if a
person still eats frequently and
snacks I don't think these other things
are going to work this is probably one
of the most important things right here
actually it's the most important thing
because when you don't eat you force
your body to live off its fat reserves
so it's like a pure fat burning
experience you can get into deep ketosis
if you combine low carb omad with
exercise and when I say omad you don't
have to start off with one meal a day
you can start off with two meals a day
but try to keep the time
close like maybe have a late lunch early
dinner and if you really want to take it
to the next level just don't eat if
you're not hungry which means you might
go one meal every other day and you're
gonna tap into like a vacuum all this
fat off your liver and pull it off
you'll see some very quick changes very
very important and that is the way to
really speed everything up but this is
like a foundational thing um and you
know what's cool about it is you're
when you don't eat your body is eating
so you're not starving it you're
actually creating a tremendous amount of
Health by not eating uh from many
different angles especially just
stripping off all this fat off of your
liver and just to go back to this low
carb thing you know the ketogenic diet I
didn't talk about what to eat right you
can find that in my video I'll put it
down below but also omed you're when you
eat certain foods what type of foods
would be good for correcting this
situation and there's a couple
interesting nutrients that I want to
share with you one is creatin and the
other is carnosine and both of those can
help you with a fatty liver both of
those can help you with increasing more
energy to exercise both of those can
help you mobilize the fat uh through the
mitochondria down here and produce more
ATP efficiently and those two
compounds creatin and carnosine are the
highest in like red meat so I would
highly recommend doing red meat several
times a week or hamburger things like
that from a quality Source grass-fed
grass finished red meat or steak because
you you have a lot of factors in there
you have a lot of nutrients there's
virtually no carbs and you have that
carnosine and creatin that can help you
um and I'll put put the studies down
below um I I don't even think you need
to take them as a supplements just get
it from Red me all right number six it's
staying
very
aware okay and not slipping into this
emotional uh thing that people go
through these different holidays staying
very aware of what works what doesn't
work of your past mistakes
and just don't keep making them so keep
your awareness up and kind of like just
be in the present right and so you don't
kind of slide into this thing I think
this is very important too because this
will help you be consistent right
because you're GNA do all these things
it's going to work and then you want to
just keep building on your successes so
what I like to do is just each day get
better and better and better okay you
screw up good then correct it do better
and keep implementing the things that
worked and then get rid of things that
don't work okay so I think this is going
to be important too because how many
people just either forget what they did
or just ignore it they just slide into
this whole thing which U the logic goes
out the window and so does their health
so anyway I think these actions can
really take you to the next level if you
want to get rid of your belly fat or
whatever you want to call it central
obesity visceral fat or whatever now if
you want um special content that is not
on YouTube you should go to my site
drberg.com I'll put a link down below
and sign up on my newsletter because I'm
going to be releasing some really great
things that you're not going to be able
to find on YouTube because they're kind
of filtering out certain things so
anyway click the link down below get
signed up and I will see you on the
other
side